Nothing says Galentine's Day
like a night out with the girls.
But as we all know, that's not happening.
So when a viewer named Ayanna reached out
for advice on planning, something special
for her and her friends.
I had an idea, but first take a look.
Hi Drew.
Me and my girls love Galentine's.
In the past we've done bowling, wine tasting
and maybe a vision board party or two,
but this year is a lot different because of the pandemic.
Shameeka and Danisha are two of my best friends
and we wanna do Galentine's this year.
My girls are all so very inspiring
and they really have my back.
We do volunteer work with each other and support each other
as women entrepreneurs and girl bosses.
I need your help Drew.
We wanna have a little fun, and I'm wondering
if you have any fun Galentine's day ideas.
(audience clapping)
Well I do, welcome Shameeka, Danisha and Ayanna.
(audience cheering)
Hi Drew.
I'm so excited to hang out with you guys.
I really feel like we've got some,
we've got a good idea cooking here.
Now, how long have you guys been friends?
So we've been friends for over 10 years.
These ladies have been there for me.
They always have my back and wow,
I can always count on them.
Always.
I love that.
And Danisha what do you love about Galentine's Day?
Drew, I love the fact that these ladies
are my Charlie's Angels, my tribe
and I get to celebrate them today.
And this is a fantastic, thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
Oh, there is something very powerful
about a trio of ladies.
I'm not sure what it is, but it works.
I'm so glad to hear that.
Okay, Ayanna, have you ever done an art class together?
Well, you know, we've done some art classes,
like a vision board parties and things like that.
And Shameeka has like a bit of a more formal art training.
So,
listen,
we put together a little art class and it has a twist.
I'm gonna show you the subject you'll be drawing.
Meet Gabriel.
(audience cheering)
Hi Gabes!
Hey.
Gabriel, you're like a Yale graduate, right?
I am.
Yeah, don't be, don't be fooled here
with his boxers and his gorgeous positioning.
Now Fleur Childs will be your instructor today.
Hi Fleur.
Hello, thanks for inviting us on the show today,
we're so excited.
Well, tell us the name of your company, please.
Sure, the company is called The Artful Bachelorette,
and we've been helping people find their inner honest,
for eight years now while appreciating the human form.
I love it.
Okay, so what are our girls gonna be doing today?
Right, you've met beautiful Gabriel.
He is one of our most popular male muses,
and he's going to inspire you
for our Galentine's Day special.
Do you think you girls will be okay
drawing Gabe for the next hour?
Yes,
yes.
Absolutely.
(audience clapping)
All right, girls, are you ready?
Yes.
Ready, set, draw.
(audience clapping)
We're gonna see you through out the show,
and check in on how you're doing.
Let's check in with our Galentine's day artistes,
ladies, Shameeka, Danisha, Ayanna.
How's it going?
It's going great.
I'm loving this.
You got anything to show us so far?
Or are we waiting for a big reveal?
Big reveal.
Definitely a big reveal.
And Fleur, our headmaster, hello,
and Gabriel, comfortable?
You know it.
Love it, all right, we're gonna check back in
with you guys a little later.
Earlier in the show,
we invited a group of girlfriends to take part
in a drawing class to celebrate Galentine's Day.
And our girlfriends have been busy with their art creations
but it's time for them to drop their pens
and reveal their finished products.
Alright, Shameeka, Danisha, Ayanna,
are you ready?
Yes.
One, two,
reveal.
The big reveal!
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh.
That's wow.
I'm really impressed.
But you know what?
Don't take my word for it.
Fleur,
the mistress of the art class.
What do you think of everyone's work?
I mean, this has been such as treat.
Shameeka is a real talent.
Like she's really got some wonderful skills there.
I'd love to see all of her artworks.
And then we have Ayanna who I think,
is definitely a personal favorite with her swipe right humor
on the bottom of these exercises with straight lines only.
And so they had to put Gabriel who is an organic form,
into a whole bunch of straight lines, which was super fun.
And then Danisha is just super cute there,
and I love all of her lines and her cheeky smile of Gabriel.
Well, I mean, that's really impressive actually
because here's my drawing.
I decided to just go along with you guys.
This should make you feel good about all your paintings.
(all laughing)
You guys are all winners and we wanna make sure
that you get to celebrate together as soon as it is safe.
So we wanna give you the ultimate Galentine's getaway
in Palm Springs, California.
(cheering)
Oh my God!
Yeah, you're gonna enjoy a six nights, seven day stay
in the presidential suite.
What?
At The Westin Mission Hills Golf Resort & Spa,
presidential suite, overlooking the stunning mountain views,
in the Southern California Desert Oasis.
You're gonna enjoy multi-cuisine and spa treatments,
courtesy of Visit Greater Palm Springs.
And the three of you will fly courtesy of jetBlue.
And Gabriel, we have a special robe just for you.
It's a Drew Barrymore look, that's for you.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you.
Gabriel, the Yale Graduate and good dads club.
May you adorn that robe in your cozy cozies
when you need it.
Thank you, Shameeka, Danisha and Ayanna.
Thank you Fleur and Gabriel, happy Galentine's Day you guys,
this was so much fun.
(upbeat music)